[Music]
all right we're gonna have a lot of fun
today we're gonna have a lot of fun in
this this session we're going to keep it
very engaging and which means that you
know you need to step up and ask
questions and challenge the speakers
challenge me the way we're gonna run
this is in the first 10 minutes I'll
speak and I'll tell you a little bit
about my perspective on this it's about
ten years since I started working on
this in this area and I want to sort of
share that with you a few of you may
have heard this before because I
actually had a little workshop last week
and I said the same thing so for you
guys just focus on your work for now but
anyway so ten minutes I'll speak and
then we'll give twenty minutes to each
speaker that takes and there are four
speakers that takes us up to one hour 30
minutes but we will not end there the
way everything you set out we actually
do have a half our budget and buffer and
I'm gonna use that to have a discussion
with all the speakers I'll ask them some
questions I expect you should ask them
some questions and we'll make it
interactive there are five seats here or
six what is it yeah so there's one extra
in so we have a surprise guest you know
who you are you're here already
okay with that let me begin
all right this session for those of you
who is on intelligent edge so if like
they say in the plains you know if
you're not the right flight you probably
want to go okay that joke didn't work
sorry okay so I'm gonna say a few things
about my own personal journey on this so
before I say this has been hammered into
you I think by now but I want to take
this time to do it as well Microsoft
Azure is large it's very very big it's
very complex you know serving as these
numbers sort of indicate there are so
many moving parts as the network is
massive
33,000 plus miles of lead fiber across
our lands more than hundred thousand
miles of fiber inside our data centers
millions of components millions of
servers all interconnected packets
flowing from one point to another point
it's it's an engineering marvel in some
sense it's planet-scale it's huge
and as you think about research you can
start to start to see that you know we
need discipline a lot of discipline in
designing such systems and we have to be
very careful because if anybody's gonna
take dependency on us on the cloud we
better damn well stay up all the time
right
that's why people work very hard and
they worry about anything breaking at
any given point anywhere such a large
large large system in terms of in terms
of the economics of it
you also heard Marc talk a little bit
about it I had these numbers to say I
want to share them with you as well
NFI eighteen twenty three billion
dollars revenue that's a significant
amount and it's going fast up eighty
nine percent growth but I have these
numbers are from my f17 I haven't wider
updated this morning but I couldn't but
you can sort of see the numbers how fast
the growth is happening we can't build
fast enough that's the deal there's so
many customers we can't build fast
enough in fact we have to slow down to
prevent to to to avoid over-promising
but from a research that actually makes
an interesting problem to I mean if the
cloud is could be statistically
multiplexed you know we could actually
use this service again so there's a lot
of researchers at Microsoft in my group
and close eye groups that that do that
and so you can also see from this number
90% of the biggest largest companies in
the world depend on it so it's all good
so that sort of sets the stage for
things all right so how did this thing
start for me in 2000 have the right idea
in 2008 i invited satya from CMU many of
you might know him too to come to
microcell research in building 99 and we
had a one day
brainstorming session on what does it
mean to what is going to happen after
cloud things change - in fact I would
challenge you to think like that - 20
years from now what is the world going
to look like right so that's kind of
sort of what we were talking about and
then our other discussion came out this
page paper this is the paper that people
saw that the site as cloudlets and we
published this paper initial thoughts
you look back at it you sort of think
okay well you know we could do things
differently then this is the first
article that came out and December 13
2009 which says how the cloudlet will
beat the cloud this is the edge so think
of it as the edge the intelligent edge
and if you look at the citation count
which I just did while ago you can see a
paper is very heavily cited so a lot of
people have read it or working on it in
a in a publishing on it now in the
faculty summit of 2009 I did a demo of
edge networking and the demo was the
actual what is now the Skype translator
we literally I mean I was sitting here
Otto is with me and we offloaded this
translation capability to the edge on a
phone and then he was talking in Spanish
I was talking in English and we were
doing this in real time and then we
published the paper with the programming
model for that of how programmers will
do that and that shoe has been cited
quite a bit since then
okay so then I had this opportunity we
have in Microsoft research we have this
thing called the DTR or disruptive
technology review where researchers can
go every year happens every year now
starting to happen every two years but
can sort of go and talk to the CEO and
the entire SLT they come into the
building ninety nine and tell them about
what trends or what things we think can
either disrupt us or we can do to
disrupt the industry and so in that I
actually presented this I presented this
if we look at this picture you will sort
of see this cause Maui node that's the
paper that was referring to but really
this is kind of the edge right and this
is the cloud and one of the things I
said that think the slide is from that
time was that here you have this
wireless things you have access points
you've got the switches
and here right next to the switch is
your edge note that was the imago you
know it and then you know we talked
about it but I made a mistake
Steve Ballmer who was a CEO asked me
okay Victor what do you think we should
do differently today right he didn't ask
me about the future he asked me what do
you want me to do today and that was a
question I did not expect the shame on
me now I look back at my life and think
that was shame but think about it as
researchers we always focused right
you're always saying oh we can do this
we do this well he was here to see you
asking me what do you want me to change
right now and I stumbled on when I told
him speech speech recognition I think I
said the speak translation or something
and there was an EVP there and he didn't
buy into it
he said not needed and in some sense
he's right and when we have all this
stuff going in the cloud and works but
so that was sort of didn't really work
so I went back and I you know I kept
working on this stuff I really believed
it and then I had another chance in 2014
actually mm that was for 2013 but we did
it in 2014 I don't know the chance in
front of the SLV but this time I took
the problem on differently I wanted to
make the case that look in the cloud we
sell storage and we sell computes I want
to sell latency ok latency is the hard
hard thing because you don't have
control many of it you don't control the
internet so then logically you will
immediately says well one thing is to
make many many data centers around the
world the other and that's not you know
financially viable so the other is hey
let's put lots of edges around the world
right so that was thing and I showed in
this video which I want to show you I do
have a point after all this so let's not
spare me for a second so I wanted to
watch this video carefully and tell me
what you see
so there are seven people walking
there's a camera that's taking this the
original video right now we're gonna do
face recognition on it with two to five
millisecond latency on the edge and you
should see that and then we can run the
same program this is four years ago
right so things are better now with 7585
and the reason we used 7585 was because
LTE rule of thumb is about 70
millisecond latency what did you see
different in the two can anybody people
have seen it don't please say whatever
did anybody see anything different in
this
come on it wasn't okay that's Ana's
Aysen anybody else would you like me to
play the game yeah yeah that's true -
I'll do it one more time and one is it
worse so there's the original original
video then there is a video with face
recognition five minutes five veneer
floating 5 milliseconds away time and
then there is 77 5 milliseconds away
afterwards so that's the first one and
now here's the second one with the LTE
Layton sees the do you see this before
that's exactly right
there were seven people seven were
recognized in the second case there were
only four that's a serious problem
that's a functionality problem imagine
that something like that somebody else
does and you're you're actually losing
serious functionality there you can't do
it the system can't do it right it's not
fast enough so this is what I showed I
actually showed a bunch of other things
- well I'll show you another one which
exceed mika-chan
does this is gaming fast action gaming
that was happening and so Eduardo you
know he's playing this game he's a he's
a top-notch gamer and he plays the games
with five second 30 millisecond latency
and 40 millisecond latency
now this particular video all you're
seeing is I just point out because we
don't have time here is really when he
clicks there's lag right between the
click and what he sees
so now if you transmit this to a surface
more serious game where he's fighting
somebody and it's shooting what you see
is that as we increase the latency he
goes from killing everybody and winning
the game to a point where he gets shot
all the time because he reacts but his
reaction time is slow
in the game is still playing and boom he
loses the game
so that's not gonna work so if you do
say cloud gaming you know it's not gonna
work unless you match the latency so I'm
gonna just move forward so so I made
this prediction after that in the DTR I
said the world is now moving in this
direction okay so you got this mega
clouds you got to have a disaggregated
cloud you know not going to be able to
sustain mega clouds for various various
reasons and it was sort of the
prediction was raised by 2020 everything
is going to look very different alright
and I was actually when I'd made this
talk I had actually gone through many
examples of what are the different
advantages of edges right you can read
this I'm not gonna belabor the point
because you can hear more from people
here but this was not just a prediction
made a sewer systems built showed this
was happening so what happened after
that meeting is this is just before
Southie became the CEO Steve stop
Ballmer asked me how much is gonna cost
in Satya who was in the audience said
three hundred eighty million dollars for
us to go do this and so and Steve said
do it do it I'm like shocked i won
well not really it's one thing to get
senior management to agree it's another
thing to get the people who actually do
the stuff to agree and that's where
everything gets stopped so what in the
meantime the world was kind of evolving
- I mean Satya had gone and created his
own you know if you go he has done
tremendous work since then he was a he's
a true believer there and then I've seen
the world sort of moving all the
different directions as well a lot of
like this conference was created I was
part of that and before consortium was
created by the way I hate the word fog
hey and I also think they ripped off
many of the things we did and just call
it fog but that's okay and I actually
have proof for that but that's not so
then but we still I was still not happy
because where's the money
where is the money we needed a killer
app so then we had this observation
there was a lecture in sabbatical and
the solution happened that there are
cameras everywhere
there are millions of cameras everywhere
they're streaming video nobody's looking
at that computer vision and AI were
becoming big systems were good so then
we started working for four
years we have worked on video analytics
trying to show and yes I still believe
there's a lot of money here and I still
believe this is the edge story from my
perspective and we did some good stuff
here we actually won two national awards
because the work we did here then
something interesting happened I always
worked I was using this work yeah I mean
like Microsoft talking to all of my
colleagues and then in December of 2016
this guy he's a VC if you don't know him
he's a well-known we see from Silicon
Valley he gave a talk entitled the death
of cloud in that talk he he basically
made the point for intelligent that she
talked about AI he talked about you know
doing the latency thing pretty much very
very similar to what we had been sort of
talking about here but it was outside it
wasn't the VC he was you know he's a he
funds companies and things of that
nature boom it became a it became a big
thing in the meantime well you know I
have great respect for our CEO and the
reason I have a lot of respect for sat
there is well first he's very he has
empathy and I like that but another
thing he's a smart guy he's his he has
he has his finger on the pulse of what
is happening in the world and he watches
it he observes it he talks to it and
then he makes decisions right so he's
along he knows we're doing this but then
he starts to see this and then he goes
out there and says intelligent edge we
are going we're all in it
Microsoft is all into that it's not just
the cloud stories intelligent history
now things start to move in a really
really big way so hey this is what he
says in Bill 2017 but he had started
saying this already as you can imagine
in the meantime a lot of research
reports start to come up edges that edge
is gonna be the thing and this is just
one example of one of those reports
there are many who came over about how
the edge will eat the cloud I actually
don't believe that at all and we will
bring that up into the panel and then of
course you start to see news articles
you start to see people getting excited
there's so many I just
some samples here just to say that you
know all these it was becoming a big
thing all right
then another big thing happened so
Microsoft announces that we're gonna
invest five billion dollars in IOT and
in the text it talks about the
intelligent edge as one of the key
components to the five billion dollar
investment now things are hot really hot
you've got a hundred and ten billion
dollar company saying that we're gonna
start investing in this that's
significant now people are starting to
move pretty hard you're gonna start
hearing Arjumand is one of our speakers
and he's going to fill in a lot of the
gaps that I'm leaving here but I'm just
taking we're talking about it from my
perspective of how exciting things are
getting for me then a couple days ago
I am the p-switch I was a beast year of
this symposium on edge computing I'm
sitting there and listening to the
papers you know if we had all these
paper discussion to figure out which
papers to accept I start to see papers
in all these different areas but
age-related as related papers this is
really exciting now we've got businesses
starting to say this is big
you got the VC community saying we are
ready to invest you got researchers
pointing out all the different issues
which is going to keep them alive
working for several years and these
provide these problems and their
solutions are quite innovative if you
think about it you have something now it
is not no longer a fad there's nothing
that this is something very concrete
because these problems will get solved
for example one of the problems that
still exists is availability in an SLA
in clouds we have SL A's so if you
depend on something you say it'll be
there when you introduce edge what's the
SLA what's the evil availability a lot
of papers on that yeah and since it's
early work they were all these the whole
so we didn't accept all of them but you
can sort of start to see this you saw
things of like management when you have
imagined that you've got not just one is
now you've got tens of thousands of s
way more than the cloud how are you
gonna manage it who's gonna own the edge
is it gonna be like the companies like
Microsoft or is it going to be sort of a
federated model where somebody else on
the edge
we don't know so as you think about all
this stuff you think what about privacy
what about security in Flour we can
offer you some level of security because
we kept everything in lock and key now
the edge is sitting on your premise
somebody can come take out the disk copy
it put it back you know who knows what
happened right real serious problems
come on so so my final thoughts here are
the there is a paradigm shift that is
happening and it is going to be very big
I predict I just looked at some report
and it says this year is the year of AI
or an edge I didn't focus too much on
the intelligent part of it I'll leave
the speakers to do and with that we
start this thank you and then we will
start the thing by having four speakers
I'm really excited to have them is mom
here yeah come on are we going to speak
in this order so let me introduce you to
monk he is many of you might know him he
was actually the director and investor
of the edge lab in Princeton so well
thank you victor very much what a
pleasure to be here thanks for the
invitation
and as Victor said that my day job is
the Dean of College of Engineering at
Purdue now since a year ago but a mine
nighttime and vacation and weekend is
research in networking and continue to
do that part of that is still a visiting
appointment to direct edge lab at
Princeton and the other is participating
in the open fall consortium a victor now
we have debates about the use of english
words like fog or edge and i'm gonna
just brush that aside for the next 15
minutes here since the last five minutes
trying to get Mac and the Microsoft to
work together I'll try to be brief here
and the main message is a network
decomposition and what is that well the
job I like the CEOs job you've got a
great one and Victor is to sort of
decide who does what at what time scale
and how to glue them back together so
it's not just allocating the resources
but also allocating the functions and
how each function is carried out is less
or becomes
for the decomposition itself
now there's the vertical decomposition
layering as a fundamental concept in
networking to modular eyes a complex
interacting system and layering candy
mathematically understood as
optimization to conversation both
reverse engineering and also a design
synthesis for engineering and for
example Kumar was one who gave me and
many in the community a lot of
inspiration back this is 15 plus years
ago also on the notion of architecture
and thinking about layering that way now
this subject that Victor is putting
together panel this morning on
intelligent edge now I think of the
cloud and edge slash fog as a horizontal
decomposition and all the architectures
in some sense are there to be a little
philosophical if you will and then to
support a range of practical
applications for example in 1948 and the
Shannon source channel separation is an
architectural principle and very crisply
stated mathematically as well and that
principle in architecture further led to
the applications of digital
communications and when mr. Bob Kahn did
the tcp/ip published in 74 and that is
an architectural design and that led to
the vertical applications in the
internet and web and the edge and fog my
biggest hope is that it will continue to
be worked on by the community from
industry and academia around the world
and arise these architectural
foundations for applications such as IOT
and v g or dispersive a is so I'm gonna
a brief abbreviate my personal journey
much shorter here back about the decade
ago started a Princeton edge lab back
then I got to interesting question one
is one large fortune
500 company told me the word edge has
been not Microsoft has been trademarked
so I have to stop using the word edge
lab and the Princeton lawyer wrote
something back and then never heard
anything from them again the other is
that people told me a moment you know
well you know I like you and stuff but
you're on the wrong side you know
everything will move away from the edge
edge would be dumb have you heard of the
word cloud and distributing functions
weathers computation storage or
computing or control to the edge and
then back to three years ago was the
founding member of the open fog
consortium now one could ask why do you
not like the word edge anymore after a
few years I say well not really I don't
particular care about English word and I
know that for example Victor thinks that
fog is a very vague foggy word and why
don't we just keep using the word edge
but you know if there is an industry
including Microsoft Cisco Intel and
quite a few others want to get together
use a term I say that's fine with me too
and decomposing functions along this
c-to-t continuum cloud to things
continuum so this is sort of a wrong
picture to show but let me first tell
you what is perhaps useful about it
first
now on the one side you've got the cloud
on the other side you got that looks
like a fog or mist or whatever you call
it now the interesting point is that you
need both
now Peter Levine's provocative essay to
say the death of cloud you know might be
exaggerating to make a point I don't see
the death of cloud I see the rise of the
edge and fog and depending what you want
to do what belongs to Caesar goes to
Caesar what belongs to God goes to God
and now this picture is however also
wrong because it is not a dichotomy it
is a continuum there is no digital sort
of boundary to say yeah
is a choice between either and or and
furthermore the pendulum swings back and
forth the time scale is about what 15 20
years or so
so some argue that there is nothing new
Under the Sun and then merely swinging
the pendulum every two decades or so
whether there's NSF or industry or PhD
thesis and perhaps is not that cynical I
think every swing brings new ideas and
driven by new context - but it is true
that the rise of the cloud and then now
there's the rise of the age and fog then
a big believer just like Victor myself
but I won't be surprised that 10-15
years later at Microsoft faculty summit
whatever twenty thirty four people would
say oh you know this edge thing is just
so like 2028 we should go centralization
we should look at economy of scale and
somebody in the audience will say I
regularly remember when I was young
there's something called cloud so this
pendulum will keep swinging and and that
is fine there are many topics as Victor
is saying one could talk about in in
edge intelligent edge or fog including I
think the economic side of it is very
important how do you incentivize the
security privacy is important but let me
just focus next ten minutes particularly
on a dispersive AI as one of the in my
mind three main pillars self-application
verticals so here you again want to
leverage the fact that you got latency
on your side latency in two ways first
you can do edge analytics or stream
mining with the life streaming of data
coming to you and you can understand it
right here right now the other is you
dare to put in some feedback control
loop because you know that latency and
perhaps more importantly jitter is much
more under control is small and
almost deterministic latency so you can
run control loops in cyber-physical
systems now you got to decompose the
machine learning computation and control
into disparate components and then they
will be working either collectively or
jointly and you can think about pre
positioning and so on so this is about a
year ago we did some demo of one
particular platform that we did at
Princeton think of this as a MapReduce
for ads or fog and what you want to do
is to look at opportunities to frame how
would you decompose machine learning
computations in order to map to this new
substrate okay so I'm going to fly
through some slides here but the typical
chart you want to see this is just a toy
example last year is to say well between
the one extreme and completely on the
device the other extreme and completely
on the cloud what happens in between
well there's a trade-off between what's
done locally and what is coordinated
community communicated globally you want
the summation to be smaller than either
end and that's a little comparison
between what we did and spark the unique
feature really is that you've got an
edge or fog to size on the challenging
side there is heterogeneity unlike the
cloud you don't have racks of servers
that run on the same OS and similar
hardware capabilities you've got
variability even volatility because
unlike a rack of servers these little
things they move perhaps and they may
not always be available and you got
constraints bandwidth for sure and maybe
even battery constraints
but on the other hand you also got the
nice things such as proximity physical
proximity to sensors and actuators so
the challenge is to take care of
heterogeneity variability and
constraints and take advantage of the
proximity now how would you decompose a
job you know whether is you know
counting words in a file or slightly
more interesting let's say run run of
least squares for example all right one
of the simplest things you can think of
if you run a large-scale least-squares
as embedded in the loop of some
particular optimization the for machine
learning you know how to do that by
decomposing the job into parallel
computation on a rack of server very
very well but how would you decompose
that job over a very different substrate
the ad Fox substrate so here are two
tort examples to illustrate in this
notion of decomposing the computation
over this kind of substrate one is about
junk camera working with tension surely
in my lab so imagine now in this
particular application topic you've got
the outdoor say sports event like the
FIFA World Cup soccer and people have
thought about using cameras over cross
wires for example but if you use Jones
to capture and to transmit what would
happen right so here is sort of one way
to look at the choices are of
architecture on the one hand you can
make everything locally done but then
you lose the collaboration you may miss
some of the important scenes in the
coverage and you may have to reduce the
video transmission right out of those
drones on the other hand you have a
fully centralized version of it and
you have to make decisions essentially
now this cloud could be the azure cloud
way out there or it could be even a big
server on the ground that big server to
all the little Jones feels like the
cloud it's just like you know a little
rock to us may feel like a mountain to
the ends so but you're gonna suffer the
round-trip time that means the ability
to coordinate in real time in response
to game dynamics will be limited so here
is one particular decomposition I'm not
arguing this is the best the
decomposition even for this application
but you see that the Jones form laid a
fog net were among themselves they would
take care of the following functions
trajectory planning and collision
avoidance and then there is a little
central coordinator for next target
location optimization and deciding which
Jones should be doing what so you've got
eight Jones let's say up in the air
which of those should help you to cover
the scenes and which should help you to
relay the video streams so that will be
done with coordination so there is still
controller up there and then you've got
the sensors on the boss and the players
and then you got the say eight whatever
number of Jones up in the air so the
Jones now they got to decide to cover
they got to decide to transmit and you
can do other fancy things 3d rendering
and so on if you want to do that in real
time and there is actually a trade-off
between maximizing coverage and
maximizing throughput and you only got
that many Jones
so for each Jeong should that Joan help
with coverage or should that help with
relaying and enhancing throughput it
turns out you can run an integer
programming joint optimization and there
are some heuristics will allow you to
solve it very fast even though not truly
optimally
just a little chart to show what we did
I guess illegally on a field on Sunday
mornings near Princeton I shouldn't say
that probably legally are flying the
drones and you look at the trade-off
over there
in this particular case it turns out
that you've got a Jones fall of them to
focus on coverage fall of them to focus
on streaming is the best now which is
covering which is streaming that depends
on the real-time situation and that is
actually coordinated by the cloud if you
will so the message here is not about
the application per se we can go into
that detail on another day but to say if
you want to coordinate group of Jones
working with each other certain
functions can be done by themselves on
the Jones and others should be done on
the ground with a little server so the
second quick illustrative example is
something that just we were doing it
last month it's still ongoing is some
preliminary results here to share it's
about a RvR and particularly the
technical problem of object placement so
that they don't block important things
and don't confuse the viewer and we want
to personalize the placement challenge
the question is where do you learn about
the personal preferences and where does
the learning happen by the way that is
actually the Princeton edge lab outside
in the corridor over there and those are
the Holograms in that experiment so
again the main message is that there's a
variety of choices in network
decomposition here during the policy
learning phase there is a user there's
an agent and the agent will try to mimic
the user and learn what is the personal
preference of overlapping and
foreground/background placement of the
holograms and then there is secondly
a policy execution phase after you've
gone through the learning phase and in
both phases you can either have a little
server there or you can have the end
device in this case the they are set to
do the computation and what we found in
this particular case is a trade-off
whereby the policy is learned with the
computation primarily on the little
server next to these AR devices but then
in execution the parameter choices of
the learned policy is done in real-time
and that's not against surprising
trade-off but it's one that sort of
worked and this is a quick video one
minute I'll probably skip in a few
seconds on the left hand side will be is
the user on the right hand side is the
agent this is during the learning phase
you want to learn the policy before you
execute the policy in real time and it
shows how the right hand side agent is
learning quite efficiently based on what
the user is doing to start it out if you
still remember 15 seconds ago way off
you know whether the hologram should be
placed in covering the real object or
behind the real object where it should
be but within 10-15 iterations I learned
very fast let me just skip to the next
slide there
so one way to visualize that a learning
process is after a few demos basically
all those little dots are the decisions
by the agent learning the user
preference and personalized placement
and that they all aggregate to the
correct place now what is interesting is
that if you don't use state space
reduction then even after many more
rounds used to are all over the places
on the left hand side is you do use
state space reduction right hand side is
you do use it and you can clearly see
the benefits now the state space
reduction is carried out not on the AR
themselves but on the on the little
server so again the main message there
is not about AR placement
personalization is that there's a choice
of where do you carry out the learning
and one possibility is let the policy
stay in the cloud if you will and let
the actual parameter and execution stay
on the end devices so the overall
question really is where as in the
horizontal decomposition where do you
place a function and we have him got to
the point of where you place the data
and what is the interface among these
modules over there so my last slide is
just to highlight what is perhaps
obvious on why is it even interesting to
explore that today and I think of the
acronym scale I learned that if you want
to write a winning NSF proposal you have
to come up with good acronym although
this was refuted abaya
by by jim crow see last night to me that
it that's not necessary condition but I
guess it doesn't hurt so s is the
potential advantage on security the less
distance it traverses more privacy is
potentially protected one could argue
the other way to say well these little
things trusting them with more and more
functions but they are easier to hack
into
and their update is not done properly
cognition is because you are much closer
to the end-user an ambience you have a
better understanding of user centric
objective agility just refers to the
fact that generally speaking you go into
the cloud the core network of LTE and so
on you go through 3gpp and it takes
forever to update and change whereas if
you rely on that end devices the agile
development process is much faster
latency were mentioned that's the number
one reason as Victor also highlighted
that people think about why do I even
care and need anything other than the
cloud and efficiency is actually
interesting there's the D to D
efficiency ok device talking to device
but then there's also the device for
device before de efficiency that because
you have proximal distance you can Luber
eyes the idle resources connectivity
computation and so on there are in
physical proximity to each other
so SCAL ye these are the reasons I think
of why networking composition
horizontally closer to the users add fog
is becoming ever so more interesting
thanks
[Applause]
and ask the question and I'll answer I
will do it so great pleasure to
introduce Amaka shore Ramachandran he
actually goes by the name kishore anyway
okay so anyway so he got his PhD from
University of wisconsin-madison he is
now a professor at Georgia Tech his
interests are in parallel distributive
systems and as you can see he's been
working on this space for a while
he's quite passionate about providing
connectivity and services in the rural
areas I actually was there in one of the
NSF workshops you had actually organized
with Aneesh and quite fascinating with
that please take it away
well I mean there's a debate that that
vikram started victor started with edge
versus frog but let me ask you a
question Oh Victor is real first name
any of you know among what is the what
is the name you know part of me
Paramveer is a real first name and and
and it means supreme hero and you should
ask him during the panel during the
panel part ask him where he got the new
holy got the name victor so so I think
moon and and Victor both of them gave a
nice segue to what I'm going to talk
about and my title the title of my talk
is as making elevating the edge to be a
peer of the cloth so that's the field
that I'm going to talk about and the I
mean of course I won't be standing here
but for all my students who've done all
the work there
sort of highlight a little bit in
describing what we're doing so my thing
IOT and the scale of applications that
run on the IOT all these are things that
you all are familiar with and and the
key thing that among and Victor pointed
out is that up future applications on
the IOT infrastructure is going to have
this characteristic of sensing
processing and actuating
and which means that levy becomes very
critical in going from sensing to to
actuation and cloud computing as we know
it is great for throughput oriented
application but not latency sensitive
applications there are also other
considerations regulatory considerations
and backhaul bandwidth and so on all of
these may argue for moving the
computations away from the cloud and and
that's where fog edge computing comes in
and and there is a moon pointed out it's
really a hierarchy of devices all the
way from you know the client devices to
routers to service all the way to the
cloud right so that's the continuum that
exists in this in this world and now
what I want to emphasize is the fact
that today edge computing as we know it
it's a slave of the cloud and and you
know there are lots of very interesting
platforms that have been designed
aardman is going to talk about IOT as
your edge cisco has its own iox plat
platform but all of these require that
the coordination is coming from the
clock and and and and there's a great
example that that move already pointed
out in terms of drones coordinating is
one another so that's the idea behind
warning to sort of elevate the the edge
to be a peer of the cloud and today
actually we are beholden to the cloud
because if I want to send a text message
to husband I have to go to the cloud and
come back to him right and so that just
doesn't seem right to us and so vision
for the future is that the edge is going
to be becoming a peer of the cloud and
this prior art that
Victor already pointed out cloudlets and
and and and Maui and and all of them are
trying to do the following which is sort
of take computations from the as a
client devices and launch it onto onto
the onto the server that is nearby but
in the limit what we want to do is make
the edge autonomous even if it is
disconnected from the cloud and I can
give lots of reasons why this might be a
good thing because the interacting
entities if you think self connected you
know connected vehicles applications and
so on there is lot of things that need
to happen horizontally among the edge
nodes and and and even more importantly
if you think about disaster recovery and
things like that we may not even have
connect connection to the cloud and in
that case and the drone example of the
great one right so if if I have the
ability to connect to even if I have
this connections among them if I have
the ability to connect to somebody I can
actually communicate and then eventually
my information will get passed on to the
others and and we can have a happy
situation so these are motivating
reasons why you may want to elevate the
edge to be a peer of the cloud and and
there are lots of challenges making this
happen first of all as a cloud as we
know it today is so powerful mainly
because of all the infrastructure that
have gone into it right there is you
know programming model storage
abstractions pop cell systems and so on
that make it a powerful development
engine for rapidly prototyping
applications and and now we have geo
distributed edge nodes and we want to
provide the same sort of ability for
rapidly prototyping applications and
what that means is that we need powerful
frameworks akin to the cloud to be
available at the edge and yesterday I
will bring Greenberg was emphasizing the
need for making sure that recovery and
is important and which means that when
you have geo distributed data then you
have to worry about replication and
Judis
in fashion so that you can avoid you
know correlated failures that might
happen in a particular neighborhood and
so those are important and when you do
that then there is the latency
consistent latency and consistency
trade-offs that comes about right so
those are things that you have to worry
about and and and then similar to the
cloud be warned that is the same sort of
elasticity of deploying application
components rapidly and the fact that you
might have the same IOT infrastructure
that is simultaneously being used by
multiple applications makes me it means
that you have to have worried worried
about multi-tenancy and all of these are
issues that are challenging and in the
remaining time what I'm going to do is
you know lots of people are working on
interesting areas related to these
topics and I'm going to give you a
little bit of a sort of a bird's eye
view into some of our own thoughts on
addressing some of these challenges and
so I'll talk about a programming model
that goes across the continuum between
you know in some sense enabling
applications similar to what what moon
was talking about in in in being able to
sort of share information across the
edge as well as vertically with a cloud
and and then how you do do distributed
data replication and then also I'll
motivate some example applications that
might use autonomous H so that's the
thing that I want to do in the last in
the in the next 10 minutes or so but
obviously I cannot do full justice for
that and and I invite you to talk to me
or look at some of these publications
that we have here so first let me talk
about the geo distributed programming
model the idea is that you have sensors
that might be generating data and and
the application itself will be a data
flow graph that you can represent it as
a data flow graph and and what you want
to do is you know Victor talked about
what are the sls right SLA is in these
kinds of applications tend to be latency
right so given the latency properties of
the application components and the
interaction among them then you can
decide how to place them in the
both horizontally as well as vertically
in this in this continuum and and so
that's part of what this froglets
distributed programming model does is is
respecting the application properties it
places the application components in the
in the hierarchy in the continuum but
you know that's not a one-time thing
because you can have sensors movie and
and if sensors move then the faulkner
that used to be processing may not be
the appropriate want to continue the
processing which means that you have to
migrate the application component to a
node that is close to where the
production of data is so that
transparent state migration is part of
fog Lisp programming model as well and
and then multi-tenancy is something that
I already mentioned and so once you
migrate something to a different fog
node but you've left some breadcrumbs
over here and those breadcrumbs already
brought over in order to continue the
computations that's part of the
programming model in terms of
transparently worrying about moving both
the computation as well as the state of
this distributed computation that's what
this fog list programming model gives
you and and if you're interested in that
please look at this publication and and
I'll be happy to talk to you also about
that the second thing that I want to
mention is the second project relates to
the recovery aspect of it so when you
have data that is very important then
you want to make sure that the data
doesn't go away when there is failures
right and and so so one one possibility
latency is also a consideration so what
we want to do is we want to replicate
the data in order to worry about
recovery properties
so let's okay I go ahead and replicate
it in a particular way so that I can
make sure that the latency that is
important is preserved but if I do this
what's going to happen is if there is a
coordinated Korell correlated failure
that all of the readers lost right and
therefore what I might want to do is I
might want to replicate the data there
are far away from
the current location of where the plane
is being generated so that I can have
resiliency and recovery properties but
that results in poor latency right so
there is this consistency and latency
trade-off that exists and you know when
you think about some of these frameworks
that are available in the cloud wanted
to let you do is it'll say well we're
gonna give you eventually consistent see
that's all we going to give you and if
you care about strong consistency you
look at it in the application if there
is a violation of strong consistency you
have to take corrective actions in the
application and that to me is not very
satisfying so one of the things that my
student came up with this idea of a
context of interest so a conflicts of
interest is that this is a context in
which I want very strong guarantees in
the data meaning that I want to know
that anything that I read is most
up-to-date value right so so that's
strong consistency is providing being
provided in the context of interest but
from the point of view of avoiding
correlated failures what we're going to
do is we're going to also replicate it
in a faraway no but if you don't give
you get strong guarantees on that so we
give you eventual consistency for that
so that's the idea behind this Fogg
store work and again only a bird's eye
view of the details in that paper but if
you're interested in that you can look
at this this paper so that's the second
thing that is looking at the resiliency
properties and the third thing is the
fact that you have fog resources and
Mong alluded to this that the resources
are not you know multiple racks you have
limited amount of resources and and you
are having applications that are
continuously generating data 24/7 and
and and and and and in that situation
what you have to worry about is how to
place this data that is being generated
so that you can make sure that it scales
and it also provides you low latency
properties all of you good things that
you need to do and so that's the idea
behind this data fog and and in
particular what happens is that there
could be SKUs in the workload you know
going back to the game example that you
had if there is a if they're soon as the
game ends everybody is leaving the
stadium so there's going to result
a huge amount of activity around that
area and in that case the edge
infrastructure here is going to be
oversubscribed and so what we have in
data fog is ways by which we can say
what is the data that we need for
immediate query answering so these are
real-time queries can be answered by
that and and older data can be moved up
in the hierarchy to to ultimately to the
cloud and so that's the way we think
about a capacity conscious data
replication and and there are details
again on how we do that taking both the
spatiotemporal coordinates of the
location of the data and then figuring
out how to sort of disperse the data in
terms of replication so details of that
you can see in a in a publication that
Kate recently came about as well so
that's the those are the examples I have
of things that we're doing in the
infrastructure but I want to give you a
couple of examples of applications that
might use autonomous edge and so for
this I'm going to give you an example of
creating space-time trajectory of
vehicles right on the roadways now the
assumption is that you don't you know
already the layout of cameras on the
roadways and and and so in principle
might seem like if I wanted to record
the activity of all the vehicles all the
time it seems like a lot of data but but
in principle but but in practice what is
happening is every car starts its
journey somewhere ends it's somewhere
right so it's an activity and the number
of activities is bounded by you know
traffic conditions and you know where
you want to go and so on and so that's
sort of the intuition behind how we can
do this even though we can do we want to
do this continuously for all the
vehicles and so the idea is that you
know if a particular roadway you know
the camera will attach to edge notes and
and a particular roadway a site a
particular vehicle and I can say through
the Geo coordinate of this vehicle and
there's a time at which I
I saw this vehicle here and as soon as I
know this I can communicate to other
cameras that are downstream from me they
were given the direction of motion of
the vehicle and the layout of the
cameras in the in the roadways and I can
tell the downstream cameras that look
out for this vehicle and I'm sending a
signature of the vehicle to look for and
analyze the responsibility of the
downstream nodes to three identify that
particular vehicle comes along and and
so when that particular vehicle comes
along it can record that well I for this
vehicle at geolocation g2 and and in a
particular time T V - and once I have
that once this guy's confirms that yes I
found it then I can actually send this
partial trajectory that I have because
this guy and get rid of it locally right
I don't have to hold it anymore and so
you can sort of aggregate all of these
trajectories and keep it together and
and of course you can you can say well
you know we may not be able to keep all
the trajectories one point and you can
do either lazy aggregation and so on and
talk about that in a minute and also you
know as you keep on getting all these
trajectories accumulated here you might
say that some of these old trajectories
and the recent queries are for recent
tracks in which case I can even push it
into the cloud and and not do that and
we can do grey lazy trajectory
aggregation so that you can keep the
footprint of storage requirement in each
of the nodes
reasonable and and as I said the story
is bounded by the activities that is at
a particular camera and that's the
reason that it is something that is
scalable and you can do it and and again
this is only a bird's eye view of what
this paper does if you're interested and
talk to me and and what we are doing
right now is we're working with our
campus security folks you know I'm sure
that this is something that most of you
experience that every campus has cameras
and I asked my security guy what do you
do with the camera we have a Google map
and we can click on the camera and look
at what is happening there's no
intelligence and and we ask them what
are the use cases that you're interested
in and we can actually track vehicles in
real time and then record that so that's
sort of what we're doing currently with
that and another example that I wanted
to give is is in the context of social
sensing and would be what we have done
is you know there you have multiple
components in the application and again
deployed across as a connection Tinh
uation I can continue and you can have
network partitions and if you have
network partitions then you can
reconfigure and resume the operation and
and and opportunistically we can
communicate when it is possible using
drones or buses that carry edge nodes
and so on we can communicate with that
and this is again something that that
we've done before and if you're
interested you can you can look at this
publication so so with that I want to do
and it's a bunch of ongoing work and I
won't talk about that if you're
interested I can do that because I've
been asked to wrap up and so I'll wrap
up so in the final comment that I want
to make is that I hope whether it is
propagated or not but I hope I have
communicated that we want to make the
edge as a peer of the cloud and and and
and and Viktor articulated how this is a
disruption that is coming and and and
and and in order to position ourselves
for the disruption this is think the
thing that we want to be looking at
thank you
[Applause]
kind of vision the question I'd ask
Sachi talks about Microsoft as a company
that can be trusted with privacy
guarantees I was anyway I gave you
privacy guarantees security for data I
was sort of expecting between the two
tops so far that that that somebody
would start to talk a little bit about
the privacy implications of edge and of
course here you are looking at who might
be driving a car where they're driving
to and who's with them that's very
clearly in this space so I'm just
curious to know what your thoughts are
about very valid concern and so for
instance when I talk to the campus
security folks they said well are you
going to publish this count with these
camera feeds on on YouTube I said no I'm
just using it for analysis and and and
then recording it and we're not doing
anything more with that but absolutely
right that you know privacy
considerations are super important and
we have a very strong group at Georgia
Tech that is looking at security and
privacy issues I and I hope to partner
with them in in terms of looking at some
of those issues okay on that note thank
you very much again I just one comment
I'll make to your comment is that so
we've been dealing with traffic cameras
quite a bit and every city is sort of
deals with it differently some of them
for example Seattle this puts it on the
web you can go and look at it anybody
can
other places like Bellevue will not put
it on the web and then we have sort of
signed some sort of agreement with them
so there is no clarity yet and how
people are dealing with it because
there's no policy any way beyond that
real pleasure to introduce our German
Samuel to you arch month is no Street
principal program manager in the Windows
IOT Azure group he is in product but he
has been in research he was part of MSR
in fact he and I worked together quite a
bit on some projects you might remember
like Hawaii and then a lab of things
which was an IOT thing but then he moved
on to the product division and now he
thinks a lot about IOT and he thinks
about the edge and in fact
wouldn't courts owns the direction in
which it takes so why don't him to share
with you he has a PhD from Purdue so
among his yes i wanted to share with ask
him to share with you our existing
current vision of where we are thank you
Thank You Victor
it's a pleasure to be here Thank You
Victor for the invitation I've been
working with a bunch of I see very
familiar faces quite a few and so I've
been working with the community for some
time I moved off to Asia IOT which is
the azure engineering team responsible
for IOT about three three and a half
years back I lead the azure IOT edge
engineering so my team is responsible
for making edge rail and the one message
I bring to this group here is that edge
is really real there are actual
customers and I'm going to actually talk
about some of those there are actual
customers who use edge who see the value
in the edge and the cloud and they marry
the two together so there's a lot of
momentum that we see out there and I'm
going to talk talk about that so when
Victor asked me I should come here I
said what better thing to do then to
bring in some real scenarios some real
actual customer use cases and talk about
some of the challenges that they see our
customers and and and then really ask
you the community to solve some of those
challenges so let's make it real I'm
going to give you a little bit of an
introduction into the IOT patterns that
we see this is how we right now see of
course the cloud is there and when we
make a slide with a cloud the cloud
takes 75% of the space there's my design
but as would also come here we look at
IOT s things these are things around us
they're things here there are things the
vehicle is our thing smart cities
manufacturing machines robotic arms
they're all things things do two things
they generate data and they can be
actuated they can be controlled right so
these are things another thing so we
look at it in three ways his insights
when these things generate data there's
a lot of insights that you can get from
their data you can understand what is
the state of the machine you can
understand the state of the environment
in which the machine is operating
you can also because now you have
insights you can have some actions you
can do some actions on the machine on
the thing or you can take actions on
your end you can adapt some processes
and so on so that's how we look at this
data of course flows as we see it today
too from the things to insights in the
cloud and from there to actions and then
maybe actions come back to the club due
to the thing but then now if you put an
edge concept on top of it you have I'll
skip this you have the same thing you
have the same insights you have the
actions and you of course have a cloud
gateway but what you now do here is you
move some of the insights you get from
data some of the actions that you need
to do and you bring it right there on
the thing now your think the robotic on
the huge milling machine your car your
smart city your your environment like
this conference room they have become
smart in themselves because those
insights which essentially is AI machine
learning parts of those have been moved
to the thing and that's how we look at
the edge because edge and the cloud work
together now I won't go over some of the
virtues of the cloud and some of the
virtues of the edge only to say that
both of them are important in their own
self you cannot do a huge machine
learning training exercise with tons of
data from distributed nodes coming and
you only need the cloud to do that
because of infinite near infinite
resources but then at the same time if
you are looking for near real-time
latency you are looking for control
loops which can run reliably right next
to the machine you are not going to send
calls up to the cloud and
for them to come back this might not be
reliable you need those insights those
AI machine learning right on that
machine now we can talk a lot about
these these virtues of the cloud and the
edge and how they sit together and how
they augment each other but the way we
have done now coming to what we have
done the product is to create a
consistency between the cloud and the
edge and by consistency we mean the
consistency in programming models
consistency in the application model
what does that mean that means that if
there is a workload that you are running
in the cloud
imagine a stream analytics job which is
ingesting tons of data analyzing the
data and then coming out with some
statistics the same application model we
have created for the edge which means
which has which has implications beyond
just the model which means you can
actually move that same workload without
any change from the cloud onto the edge
without any modification without writing
any code all through configurations so
that is the consistency that is how
consistency between the cloud
programming model and the application
model and the edge programming model and
application model helps us it has
implications beyond just technology it
has organizational implications right so
now if you do not have this consistency
in the programming model you need
developers you need people who actually
program the cloud application and then
you need people who actually go in and
program the edge application but with
consistency and an infrastructure which
allows you to move workloads from the
cloud to the edge you do not need that
you just need cloud developers who
develop their their applications in the
cloud make parts of it which they want
or they think or they optimize to run on
the edge and simply configure it that
way and then they can move it back so
that's really how we look at the edge
that is what azure IOT edge does by the
way this is azure IOT edge there's also
another product the edge browser this is
not it this is edger IOT edge which we
are talking about
okay so now I'm going to make it a
little bit real then I'm going to stop
stop a little bit and go into some
design principles here this is a real
customer that we work with they have a
mining operation they have spread these
pumps which are spread around this very
remote locations many of these remote
locations are in the ocean they're not
even on land and then they have one
central place where they're controlling
them network connectivity to these
remote locations is very bad or very
expensive so they typically would use
satellite connectivity they can only get
alerts otherwise it becomes very
expensive so what they do and also sorry
and also reliability of operation of
this pump is extremely important because
if it goes down you lose money you lose
oil which is mine so this is their world
there is a pump here which is going up
and down similar to that one the pump
has really it's boiled down to two
values of pressure pressure above the
plunger and pressure below the plunger
and then this on the x-axis is the
position of the pump
so at all times there is an envelope of
operation for these two pressures the
minute it goes out of scope out of that
envelope this pump fails and this whole
operation goes down now obviously there
is a requirement for it to be
near-real-time so they need to monitor
this there's also a requirement to be
predictive you cannot wait for this
envelope to be broken to take some
action you need to predict when this
would happen so that it does not break
down and you can do something about this
power and you want to do it in offline
this pump could be operating in the
middle of the ocean and you do not have
any connectivity to the cloud now how
they do it is right now they would have
the pump they actually have some
automation they call it there's a
gateway there's a SCADA controller
there's an HMI right next to it and then
when that and then there's an alert
there's a supervisor sitting in the
central place there is an alert which is
generated when that and will
is broken and then the supervisor would
send somebody who would start tweaking
the pump shutting it down or doing
things which they can do to mitigate
that that issue so what they have now
done and of course moving that data up
to the cloud and training machine
learning and oil is expensive remember
this is satellite connectivity so what
they have done here right next to their
existing gateway and the pump controller
they have deployed error IOT edge this
is right now on pumps on mining
operations what it allows you to do is
to first of all have some translation
between the protocols that are happening
that are use Modbus is the protocol they
use and protocols which are more IOT
enable like MQTT but the second thing
most important thing you can actually
deploy machine learning right on the
platform on the pump and now you could
be disconnected and when that bad thing
happens you actually can control sorry
you can actually control this pump right
from there you do not need to be
connected to the club now this is a real
scenario this is what customers use
today our IOT edge today another one I
just have a few minutes another one is
using drones for a number of different
operations mostly vision video from from
drones and there are a bunch of
scenarios infrastructure inspection is
one of the most popular scenario that we
are seeing today there are miles upon
miles hundreds of miles of pipeline
which is laid out there and it's
physically not possible for somebody a
technician to go out and inspect every
inch of that pipeline so what they do is
they've started to do is fly drones over
those pipelines and then take video from
the pipeline previously what they would
do is they would collect a lot of video
bring it back to the base station and
then start analyzing that of course
meant they had a latency of a few hours
before they would know that bad things
are happening there so they're using and
I'm going to go into the scenario a
little bit more smart agriculture
there's a lot of work that has happened
just to understand how the agriculture
operation is happening drones are used
there and of course our favorite
scenario which we would like to debate a
lot about is surveillance and there's a
lot of scenarios where legitimately you
could use drones there so Ezard IOT edge
can actually sit on top of a drone the
drone that it sits on we have a
partnership with DJI which is a major
one of the world's biggest drone
manufacturer we work with them they put
edger IOT edge right on top of the drone
and then through connectivity with the
cloud you can move your machine learning
on to that that drawn then these cheaper
drones this is about $1000 that's about
$15,000 this cheaper drones you actually
can set up a base station they do not
have sufficient compute more importantly
battery to support edge compute so you
can actually deploy it on a base station
and then within that environment you can
do
ail ml and so on so so these two are
actually there soon they'll have an SDK
disable where you can actually
developers can develop using Azure IOT
edge to deploy things onto the drones
how does the whole thing work you have a
video camera which is a drone video
camera we have IOT edge device on the
drone this is a little Nvidia chip that
sits there on top of it of course in the
cloud we have IOT hub and you have a
bunch of your smarts AI n ml in the
cloud what you do is you can terrorize
them we use docker container technology
you host it in the cloud in a container
repo you could use a jar container
registry or docker repo and then you
could move containers there you build a
manifest you move it on to the drone the
manifest knows what are the different
components you need to move down onto
the drone and then azure IOT edge
runtime starts moving those containers
on to that platform and then you could
be disconnected as long as you have the
smarts which are required for the drone
to fly
you could be connected again you could
be doing it at scale so the whole value
prop here is to actually allow you to
not deploy one drone but to deploy
thousands upon
thousands of drones and keep it updated
you have a new machine learning model
which you have retrained based on data
that you got now you want to update your
drone with a new machine learning model
all you do is do a second version of
this container push it up there update
the manifest and now you get the new new
version so here are some design
principles that we we follow of course
security is one of the most important
ones that that are required for for edge
computing given the devices out there we
have invested quite a lot we have
created some partnerships quite a few
partnership with silicon vendors we have
already announced nxb microchip they
actually create the right security
frameworks for edge to work we also have
all of this is cloud managed while it
can be disconnected but to bootstrap the
device you need cloud management but it
is done at scale so we can manage
millions of IOT edge devices which are
deployed out there from the cloud we can
provision them with zero touch we can
also move configurations down onto those
devices with zero touch cross-platform
IOT edge devices you know the ones which
sat on top of the drones are windows can
be linux multiple versions of Linux as
long as the OS supports containers it
can actually deploy arrived eh portable
we have a full dev experience CI CD
pipeline and so on for this and then
extensible it's not only Asia I edger
services that you deployed it not only
Azure machine learning not only Asia AI
and so on it could be your own code it
could be your own smart AI that you want
to deploy onto the edge you simply
package it as a container put it
somewhere and then it can be deployed in
fact can you finish and then I'll come
to the question in fact what we have
done here we have created a marketplace
for all of these modules we call the
modules all of these containers to be
discoverable from where you can deploy
on to the edge and I'll briefly touch on
that so in terms of hardware anywhere
from this interactive pier is something
similar to a Raspberry Pi which can host
in containers all the way to accelerated
tears these are FPGA enabled GPU
accelerated hardware IO th can exist
there your open source as your i/o th is
on github MIT license totally open
source you can pick it up and do
whatever you want to do it do with it
it's more B based so docker is based on
mobi technology and that's what it is
based on we have a marketplace where you
can actually go in and buy this or get
these modules security intelligence we
have a bunch of tooling different
languages we have five languages in
which you can actually write these
modules CC sha
Java node Python and you can actually
deploy it deploy any of these languages
since I have a couple of more minutes
scale is one of the big challenges that
we face today scale of deployment these
mining operations do not work in onesies
twosies they work in thousands to
millions right and they asked for that
kind of scale and not just scale of
deployment but scale of management scale
of state management scale of monitoring
all of that has to be always at least a
million devices let they think of so
that's a that's something that we have
been thinking a lot about we provide
zero touch for millions of devices today
there's a lot to be done their supply
chain has to come up silicon has to
evolve and all of that is happening
adapting workloads based on hardware
Network cost so all edge devices would
not be the same they would be different
small big and so you have to upload you
have to have the right modules which go
there and how do you do that there's an
optimization problem in there which
together with Victor Steve we are we are
investigating there's a lot of work that
we are doing on security when you move
workloads cloud workloads to edge
devices deployed out there you have to
be very careful with that you have to
have the right silicon you have to have
the right models operations I talked
about that but one thing that has come
up again and again edge devices when
they are deployed even on these mining
operations are not single vendor they're
never single vendor there is the owner
of the operation there is the owner of
the pump which is different and it's
leads to them there is the oil
the entity which has interest in the oil
who's selling that oil to somebody all
of them need a slice of the data and a
slice of that operation and all of that
has to be part of our access control
models part of how we deploy and the
policies in song so just a quick
overview of the research challenges we
see your IOT edge is open source github
go and play with it and and hopefully
contribute to it as well
thank you very much but there was a
question in the meantime Lin can you
please set up so this looks like
incredibly cool stuff so I'm kind of
curious about you mentioned security and
a couple of the challenging issues there
and I don't want to ask a long involved
question about that but the question is
what is there a simple mental model for
how to think about security as I extend
to the edge and do I have to trust the
hardware do I have to trust some other
third party is microsoft gonna have some
devices so I didn't mention I also lead
security for the majority so I can
actually talk at length maybe later on
you can do that but just to talk about
quickly there is trust that is in the
cloud which obviously you trust more
because we make sure that it is trusted
what we do is we try to take that trust
and bring it to the device how we do it
is through device identity in
attestation we identify the device
through Hardware means so you know TPM
and such and then we build trust with
attestation of firmware and software
that runs on top of it and this part of
it is not only Microsoft doing it we
have to have silicon firmware
manufacturers OMS who contribute to it
to enable that we have a certification
program so we certify IOT edge devices
which conform to this whole building of
trust mechanism right so it's not any
device this if you want to be really
secure you go and get the certified
device to do that all right so I know
there are more I think we'll see how it
goes
so thank you so much again Sgt all right
so now so you're getting hopefully
you're getting a sense of different
things and different problems that exist
and your minds already churning and
in terms of where we are in the product
world where research is and where we
want to be the next speaker is a rock
star really is in fact the speaker next
to might not he's not gonna speak he's
also a rock star
he's a 2018 rock star from Sigma bile
and you are 2014 2014 rock star from the
Rising Star Award for those of you were
and other six who don't follow the rock
star thing so anyway and Lynne is a
professor at Rice University he
graduated from Princeton so and he's
I've known Lynn for a long time and he's
great thank you thank you thank you
that's a good summary thank you very
much for the invitation it's my pleasure
to talk about vision Kyle and I shared
it's a really a joint work or oh I'm the
one speaking you can talk away my based
on here right and we could also give us
a feedback about this and we're gonna
switch it to your about we're gonna talk
of 5g and try to point the link between
5g energy and water edge can do for 5g
and truly we think is 5g needs edge so
the questions are we ready right I think
so I which is coming right this is a
once a decade opportunity for us I like
to joke like my 10 year my full
professorship our based on 3G and 4G
right to the PhD smartphone take off
during a year or 4G mobile says to took
off of the conference flagship comfort
for signal walk a lot of things happen
here is a Microsoft I would say Apple
and Google ceased opportunity of 4G and
had the Android iPhone really be I'm
sorry Microsoft Windows from Mesa
opportunity but 5 G's here what about
Microsoft do what can we do right so the
takeaway is we really therefore take
away things that we think we need soft
or in the 5g network infrastructure
because soft you know fast and we should
use nets off to eat everything right we
should for self to actually eat the tech
infrastructure we have the rating too
soft was the whole soft step for
efficiency and of
and number three for Cheerios edge for
telecom infrastructure and we have the
rating of its architecture we have to
think of a disaggregated architecture
what we have to think about how to
integrate actuators into the edge cloud
and number four I think it's once you
have five cavity hive the edge cloud
there it's a great opportunity to think
of what novel new things you can do a
previous not possible many services and
I think I'm a computer engineer so I
like to think summarize my summarize the
history of Telecom I like to think of
the entire history was a telecom is
using how to work more and more hardware
to solve
the spectrum problem because hard was
cheap and it getting cheaper even
poster-boy small right but in contrast
spectrum scarce and it's determined by
physics is you're never gonna more
spectrum like even the UFC secret open
up more but 0 they are predetermined by
physics
why does communication is about throwing
resources more computation so that you
can use spectrum more efficiently and
here showed its basic massive MIMO one
the key technology for 5g you could use
a lot of antenna a lot of a parallel
passes empowering on the base station so
that you can serve multiple clients at
the same time to increase spectral
efficiency proportionally and if you
think look the fibre g5g essentially is
about using more hard wall and to
improve spectral efficiency and to
improve the latency right I think of a
massive MIMO the example think about
small cell density Perlman is far more
ApS more infrastructure and think about
you numerator millimeter wave radios
it's about moja right so we my team
actually is I would see were the first
one to build actually the massive first
mass of my research prototype number
years ago and and I've said us on the
track to actually experience the pain
the entire telecom industry is over the
past 75 years will have built three
generations of
the Argos masam I will put a tab this is
a first generation and this is latest
one we deployed on campus after 1
million dollars from myself it's the CRI
grant with the newest base station like
this this is just a newly deployed on
top of roof as a research prototype this
is a word perhaps first deployed massive
MIMO network his bed and the good news
we got for those of you who like to use
it we just got a award from myself it's
gonna make this part of the community
infrastructure it will be deployed down
campus the University of hardness so as
an open-access testbed but this sounds
like success story but I really I think
this is a failure story to me right
looking back it took seven years three
generation one entire PhD and we didn't
innovate any arabism any any new things
right basically these also regeneration
is update the FPGA when bigger bigger
every chip become available more of
thumbs eye links we need after the board
and it took seven years so this kind of
the exemplify the pain of the trigger
infrastructure specialized hardware
special equipment lead to slow
innovation expensive equipment and very
high cost of ownership and a capital
investment expenditure if you look to
history to 1 g 2 g 5 g 43 hg take 10
years at least
can't wait yourself toward make this
process faster can we soft to write the
tech infrastructure bring in low vision
what do we have saying in the mobile
cloud area to take a common structure
that's our position today like the 5 G's
infrastructure needs us also approach
and it's a great opportunity for
Microsoft asked researchers working on
the software systems and I think that
the two lessons we learned I think it's
a from our experience maximum base
station and also I think it's also a can
of the lessons from the past 14 it's a
3G deployment its number one is soft
looking the words a fast faster we
talked about it we should maximize soft
or and minimize the use of specialized
equipment
and number two I think is resource
integrations about I will talk about
this point to the points by resource
integration if you look at today's base
station look at our our Argos base
station program is a good example is all
the resources are f actuator and
hardware software both interviewing base
station and in this particular case
they're integrating this board which has
FPGA and memory and self to stack
everything it right so diet me to vary
so technology evolution because FPGA
actuator soft wall and RF they have a
different pace of innovation right some
of a faster but because you're putting
the same board in the same base station
you have to wait for the slowest won't
update update the whole thing right it's
impossible into cell resource sharing
because each of base stations serve just
that we user into cell like when when
you don't have many others but your
resource country your computation
resource there is which is sitting there
idle and number three is when you try to
coordinate two cells to base tensions
it's become difficult because the you
have to get means very high throughput
between them to to coordinate what we
argue is we need have this aggregated
video access almost like what's
happening data center we need to have
this resource disaggregated data centers
we need base station should only have RF
perhaps ABC da and will IQ samples to a
hydrogen is this our great local data
center where the computation will be a
creation or software and with this
architecture we will be able to
independently evolved each of this
technology and will be able to consult
and resource bitumen and cells and we
should be able to very easily deploy
rather any services software's to the
edge right for example localization
service now could it be in the past you
have to change each base station now you
can just put on as piece of self doing
the in the edge if you want to do for
example this is a you could also use the
self to the handle does deployment this
is an example from cows group and you
could have a very cheap access more
intense deployment and a link to
edge server exalt Allah and you can
handle the mobility and reliability in
software and all because can leverage
the the poverty of the the propagation
of a channel to improve houses a suppose
this is actually is a Cal deploy this in
Princeton campus that's a converse a
subpoena in canvas the white blocks are
the access once deployed there were
cheap and they're linked to a server
which runs a software that handle suite
the the pet the the link is switching
between this different access wants to
deal with the pass fading problem and
the blue is darlink and in the agreeing
uplink and everything is done yourself
to okay
another example this is a this is a work
victor clapper with cow and job any
power from from parents and this is how
can you use your phone to help each
other
recognize where are the available
parking space in a busy city right you
just use your phone the phone running
real real real time cars localization
recognition algorithm and some of the
logic will running in the edge and the
users they could share information help
each other found where our parking over
the parking space this also goes back
something why was on sabbatical was
victory group six years ago now Wow time
flies six years ago when the a lot of
wearable devices showed up by Google
glass we had this vision of continuous
mobile vision but the cloud your
computer personal computer always see
what do you see right therefore they can
do a lot of interesting for you actually
bought a bunch of a Google glass and and
and run soft over there and the effect
is it's gonna kill the battery in 20
minutes and also is it going to burn
your skin quickly and but I think ways
the edge cloud weighs the short latency
prominence by 5g and you can really move
a lot of computation to to the edge so
that your your your where book will stay
cool and friendly so I think important
challenges for doing the same as in
software this is move things to the
basement process and to edge I think
this we have heard the story of Clarence
irani years ago but that didn't take off
for the one the key challenges is
according by insider information for
hallway is the efficiency is terrible
running baseband processing softball in
the edge server and reliability is also
questionable compared to traditional
specialized equipment so to really to
enable software eat the 5g
infrastructure I think's very important
we think about software stack and how
can make it efficient how to make it
available as available as like a big
poppycock so one of the solutions solve
the efficiencies your actuator example
calico path show the BIOS FPGA GPUs you
actually can improve the efficiency by
many folds 20 times for example and this
could be led for integrated into the
into the edge listenger and to enable
you to update your actuator and CPUs
independently right now I think to
rethink the software stack for efficient
of ability I'm gonna say something very
controversial
I think it's there's a lot of low
handful but I think after you have
optimized for everything then you
realize the Linux operating system
I have any starting Windows kernel so I
cannot say about Windows but Linux
operators actually would eventually
become the bottleneck for efficiency
availability if we would like to clarify
that a common structure we need a new
softest step we need a new kernel the
reason is very simple because you're the
unsafe language therefore a lot of
runtime checks so you wouldn't be able
to run software fishin C and number two
the next operation have very
commoditization
to update one module you often have the
whole what's the whole system right so I
like this graph we basically it also
from Microsoft gain account and Jim
Morris alum Barry years ago they had
this project or a singularity
singularity vision is
to say hey make sure the correctness of
soft the comp our time implantation time
don't do it at runtime Linux and and see
basically you enforce Krakens runtime
which is like the airpo secure check
right every time you go to the airport
if you need to scan you right we really
need a softer stack like if like TSA
prey basically you check the correctness
offline aesthetically and when the wrong
just run fast made it wrong right so
that's one effort going on in my group
we're building a new operating system
runtime compose an opera certainly using
rust intended for years in the edge
again name is Sam rice I think I come
and see you 5g is really opportunity for
software people itself to play and there
is a lot of opportunity for EDUCAUSE
there to support the five 5g given
structure okay thank you great
presentations and giving your own point
of view on this I was sort of when Bank
presented he had a slide you had a slide
in there where you sort of talked about
some of the assumptions and one of the
assumptions you had was battery and
energy but then as you look at some of
the other talks except for the drone
case that was not the assumptions so
what that means is and you will also
encounter this which is people will have
different definitions of edge what it is
or edge clouds or you know even fog or
cloudlets or and will have a very
different definitions of it and that
just sort of shows that we are kind of
sort of evolving and try to make it more
crisper in our own head as to what it is
now one thing that you guys did not talk
about which I see as emerging very
recently in fact Microsoft announced
something and then I heard Google
announced something and I believe Amazon
also has that it specialized hardware
for the edge itself so what I have in
mind what I'm thinking about is this
notion of having
PC or server rack with some specialized
hardware what are your initial thoughts
on
specialized hardware existence
anybody can think that and you guys have
the microwave yes I think I think the
special is I think it's about
how it shouldn't be part of architecture
I think it's I think the smart make the
dog burgers they have using FPGA in the
datacenter is a good example they f PG
is not the whole thing but part of the
architecture I think I think in the 5g
infrastructure when you would try to
solve as a qualified I think it's a
using FPGA you should bring every J as
part of architecture instead of have
everything I appreciate your specialized
hard work I think you should selectively
use them for the critical path we can
oppose data plane so let me I'll let you
speak our island the rest of you too so
just to sort of be more even more crisp
there's a lot of thoughts about machine
learning on the edge you know like
there's a debate or how much you can do
in the hedge how much you can do cloud
you shrink the models to put it on the
edge but when you have specialized
hardware that's tends to open up more
more avenues to do more stuff and so
that's kind of what I'm saying so for 5g
I understand that but I think there's a
place for both there's a place for
general-purpose Hardware cpu-based
compute as well as very specialized
hardware like GPU acceleration or FPGA
acceleration and in the edge world again
workloads tend to be both but for
workloads like machine learning and very
specialized AI yes FPGA is in a way to
you GPUs are a venue we already have
brainwave which we announced a few weeks
a few months back which allows you to
download your your ml into your hardware
which has FPGA and then it fully uses
the FPGA
so that's brainwave it's already
announced we also have a bunch of
collaborations on cameras with GPUs call
comm is one of our partners where we
enable the GPUs to be used on that
camera for acceleration of 3m detection
and so on and that's all IOT edge doing
that so yes there's a place for both but
I think in the end game it won't be any
one of those I think it will always
a combination so since my core research
is really in optimization algorithms as
I hasten to comment too much on hardware
but I just want to quickly point out two
things one is that I think was kin who
asked about security and I have this
onion formed by its opinion that on the
on the edge of thought the harbor base
the security probably is a much
likely route for trust now as to the
second point is Microsoft is moving fast
and so are some of the other companies
so some of these are not a
technologically driven per se but really
is trying to tip the balance of power in
industry food chain and sometimes having
specialized Hardware may or may not be
actually of use in a particular domain
but a lot of companies certainly feel
that if I don't do something along those
lines I'll be left in the dust as the
balance of power shifts with the rise of
the edge think about wireless you think
about wireless networks and we are
seeing the limiting factor especially
with the 5g technology 60 gigahertz
small cells massive MIMO especially
limiting factors shifting from what we
do in the wireless design to the
computational power and behind the
wireless algorithms and so computation
is becoming the bottleneck and
specialized hardware is allowing us to
be more parallel in the processing that
we do behind the wireless algorithms for
the edge and so it's going to play a
huge role GPUs and FPGAs in base
stations and on the edge so I wouldn't
add that in our own experience in our
lab similar to what you were saying
about the average we built a cluster of
raspberry PI's to serve as a fork node
and and as I mentioned when I talk we
want to create the ecosystem
it's similar to the cloud so we brought
pop subsystems by kafka
and storage system like a Sandra to run
on the edge and then we were doing these
camera processing that I was talking
about and the limitation is how many
cameras frames per second that you can
do even if you have a cluster of
raspberry PI's we are limited by that
and so at that point you have to include
some additional capabilities like Nvidia
boards in order to do some of the image
processing faster so there is an
opportunity to sort of integrate for the
mundane stuff you can use off-the-shelf
components but you know for most
specialized processing you may need to
incorporate additional smarts in it I
think all about long recurring yanira
cost right you need a massive quantity
of a market to amortize the non-return
you costs you need that big number so
otherwise it doesn't doesn't doesn't
make sense in climbing code to make it
ASIC just for for machinery so you're
saying so your point is that you need a
lot lot of edges for its specialized
hardware takeoff right they use the same
the same hard work will require a lot of
deployments a lot of devices you use
them to a motorized in our contingent
follow-up question but I will the follow
question would be something like what
kind of hardware would you bet on
but let's table that because I have a
bunch of other things to ask so so I
wouldn't ask Kishore set up on another
vision right so he sort of said a vision
which was about like cloud being or edge
being parallel to the cloud and many of
you actually articulated a different
vision where the cloud and edge played
together cloud is absolutely necessary
and the edge is necessary so for those
of you who did not play nat not claim
the wisnicki sure did I want to see what
your reaction was to what he was saying
I like the vision a lot there is a
distinction between the edge use
the cloud versus the edge becoming the
cloud or replacing some of what the
cloud can do and I want to highlight
that sometimes the word cloud can also
like word adds edge and fog be used in
multiple ways so one particular example
is this is radar regarding particular
start of that I found a card data me and
D test doesn't matter but it turns out
that when we try to do billing and the
byte counting in a LTE network if you do
it in the core network which can be
drawn with a big cloud occupy only 75%
of the slide then a is expensive B is
privacy intruding and C is kind of slow
like 24 hours later the in our operator
can tell you something about the pricing
policies so if you want to innovate
pricing you've got to first innovate
doing that in the edge like amount and
user devices may be for example to
detect the peak valley condition of LTE
cell turns out that you don't need to
rely on the LT core you can actually do
some of that on the devices but the
point is that actually is echoing Kira's
point right that is an example of the
edge becoming the cloud not just using
the cloud however to do that really
efficiently you can't rely 100% in that
startups case on all the devices doing
them autonomously so we actually had a
little controller in the other kind of
cloud in the sewer or Amazon if that
doesn't trigger you know some fire alarm
here in that cloud is not the LTE core
cloud it's a different kind of cloud and
put a little provisioned controller to
enhance efficiency coordinating the
mobile devices so we still want that
kind of cloud even though this is
literally killing a function and
replacing it of another cloud so this
particular example this worked out then
we have 60 million users in the world
using this product right
but it both echos the point the edge can
replace cloud or beyond equal footing
but also highlights the point that he
still doesn't hurt to have some form of
cloud I would disagree a little bit
there
you still need a cloud the cloud and
I'll tell you what are the scenarios in
which you actually need a cloud to
bootstrap your edge devices and this is
how we do that one of them is security
or more precisely trust right when you
have all of your devices which now you
call your you know your cloud
distributed how do you build trust
amongst them and where is your center of
trust right so cloud gives you a
convenient way of saying okay Trust is
in the cloud and from there I can
actually start trusting software do
attestations trust hardware and then I
can start deploying these so essentially
there's a master/slave relationship in
terms of trust there that's one second
is is availability or high availability
scenarios which require coordination
amongst distributed computers and and
one way of course is that each one of
those nodes talk to each other do
election and so on but then you still
need some way of understanding if these
nodes are distributed widely and how do
you coordinate between them so you need
some place where they all come down to
and cloud would would allow you to do
that so and of course the final thing
here is how would you manage a very
large data set you could do that you
could create little nodes with raspberry
pies put little data on all of them and
start coordinating but it's a huge data
problem then rather than going to the
cloud putting all your data in there and
doing machine learning there because you
have almost infinite compute and
resources there and then moving your
inference down to those edge nodes so
while I do see edge becoming more and
more powerful as supporting so many more
scenarios but I still see there's a
place for the cloud in there for for
security yeah I'd like to add something
that has not been said by anybody yet so
if we go to first principles of cloud
part of it was that I sell shoes I don't
want my IT department I
somebody else will take care of the
whole thing and I'll just write you a
check and all your machines all the
upgrades all the other good stuff just
happens somewhere else saying I don't
have to I can go so she was and I think
so that's kind of like you know it was
one of the big value proposition for a
cloud you didn't have to worry about
hardware software you don't have to
worry about management it was a
computing resource available to you so I
think in the edge world you're going to
need something like that you can't I
mean if you if you build a system which
is completely separate from that you are
actually back to the old world where
you're now back to you having an old IT
department back to having all these guys
who are trying to deal with her with the
S cloud I just want to be sure that I
wasn't articulating that we get rid of
the cloud all I was saying was that we
want to put the edge on an equal footing
with a cloud and there are applications
in which that is super important so if
you think of what connected vehicles the
latency property suggests that you want
these kind of communication to happen
very quickly but on the other hand if
all that I'm interested in is knowing
the density of cars in a particular
roadway I can send all those information
to the cloud process it offline no
problem with that
right so in that sense you know there's
a coexistence that is super important
and I think cloud can play a huge role
exactly what our John was saying in
terms of management of the resources for
instance in the sense social sensing
application if partitions happen
recognizing that partitions happen and
reform re-architecting the application
component so that you can continue the
application it's something that you
would expect to happen in a central
fashion from the cloud so management
functions are super important Trust is
super important and and those are things
that is going to come from there and one
more thing I want to add which is sort
of you alluded to at the beginning when
you introduced me you know in affluent
communities we take cloud for granted
everything that we do relies on the
cloud and affluent communities and you
know Georgia Tech is located in Midtown
Georgia Midtown Atlanta and just you
know across
outside a drive there is an impoverished
area economically depressed area and
aspirations of the people are exactly
the same as aspirations of people in
affluent communities but they don't have
access to the information and services
that we take for granted and so one of
the things that I'm hoping is that you
know this edge infrastructure can
actually help in sort of addressing the
digital divide better than what cloud is
doing today
yeah that's great I'm gonna ask you one
last question we'd be five minutes or
because we started five minutes late you
guys think if you want to ask some
questions while I'm asking this
particular question so I think the the -
Kyle and you guys you know I thought
that was a that's a pretty compelling
story that you put together I also
agreed that the rate of innovation in 5c
and telco has been substandard it is way
less than what the IT does and part of
it is because they're calcified because
of the architectures that they have
created and are not able to they're very
worried about switching anything and so
the vision that you are painting here is
that get out of the hardware business to
the extent possible do everything in
software I mean the thing you didn't say
but it's implied in there is you know
take the IP network don't use your own
stack and you can do pretty much
everything you want to do after that
and then you painted the that edge is
important so the question to you and
actually to others as you think about
the talk that these guys gave what is
your opinion about the talk but the
question to you is this sort of thing
was tried in China right there was this
big project called Saran cloud ran where
they were really the ideas were saying
they said they didn't want to be held
responsible for all these standards that
take forever to do so let's take all the
signals bring it back to the cloud we'll
compute it and we give it back and it's
all but that was about several years ago
I don't know what the state now is what
did they do wrong if at all versus what
you're saying now I think the key part
that's a great question I actually kind
of touched on Syria I would give and
talk
I think Siva is the right direction
centralized
sher consolidated and using soft rope
but I think as as far as I understand
from people I know from Huawei the
equipment vendor is the electricity bill
it's just too high when you run things
it's also the base station today a macro
cell base station could already cost you
a quarter million dollars a year just
flexibile but now if you move the
processing to softwa and that's just 10
volts of electricity OHS but I think the
if we would like to qualify the telecom
infrastructure we have to make the
software efficiency get close to
specially specialized equipment that it
has multiple routes for example rethinks
itself the stack use the actuators as
part of architecture I think yeah we
have to solve this hard problem so
you're saying we have to solve but there
is no I was thinking of is there some
magic to the new architectural thinking
of saying we gotta have the edge here
and that will make the problem so if it
should be problem it'll actually be less
because we are doing this I think so let
me try to respond this is a heart a hard
question to answer the minute I respond
to one source of magic is how we could
can Co design classical network
protocols that we know with this new
architecture this new edge cloud
architecture Co design of the protocols
so for example Co designing the Wi-Fi
reliable transmission with multiple
roadside hotspots Co designing in the
cellular context in the 5g context Co
designing the base station LTE protocols
with the new architecture that's going
to be the interesting intellectual
challenges going forward I just make a
meta comment not just specific to this
question what I see right now is a huge
gap or lack of standards for edge
computing generally I know
open fog is doing a lot there whatever
you call that but we do the name itself
but there is a lot of need for different
communities to come together and work
on standards and there are disparate
standards the security standards we use
today were developed and designed for IT
world and now we are trying to put them
into the IOT world the whole container
standardization was not done for IOT
devices it was done for server class
devices and we are trying to simply
reuse that too so there's a there's an
opportunity we're not just in this area
but all of the edge the whole stack
where standardization could help okay
great is there is there a question from
the audience yeah so I thought this is a
really interesting panel and I guess my
question relates to azure IOT more than
the rest although welcome answers from
anybody um so I personally I believe
that we're gonna have an edge that's
mostly connected to the cloud but that
because of these real-time and hardware
pressures that the OS and system
infrastructure has to change because the
traditional azure is a very long stack
from external events to back-end
processing that front we heard comments
about that here we're talking about
strongly consists in real-time reactions
with hardware in the loop which are all
things that really are quite different
from al vision of what as yours fabric
looks like the hardware for example in
the loop is not really accessible to me
as a client using Azure it's accessible
to me through as your services and
they're mostly using that kind of
hardware somewhere deeper in the cloud
so I'm wondering how you see the azure
IOT evolving kind of as an operating
system or as a software ecosystem that
that enables the customer to directly
leverage for example our DMA into FPGA
clusters these are things which
Microsoft talks about all the time but
there's no doubt that they are not
viewed as end-user technologies right
now I I agree with that I mean there's a
again gaps you know we're talking about
some of the gaps and you're right in the
data center there's multiple levels of
indirection before you hit the hardware
so the layers upon layers and our
customers really get the highest level
of layer if they want and they can go
down for the edge we have tried to
create some
there which is more friendly to the
developer and hence that the user which
is through containers right so if we can
move containers around which tends to be
contained in that way we can give some
level of abstraction on top of hardware
but still you're right at the end of the
day the customer who's deploying an edge
device has to be involved in the
maintenance of the hardware the
management of the operating system and
anything above that including the
container management system so I believe
these are early days they were still
you're right they probably is an
opportunity to create an operating
system all up which abstracts all of
that for our developer as well as the
user but I don't think we are your day
right now yeah I was gonna just make a
little comment can that just stay tuned
so the things you bring up are actually
on our mind as well and what you see
today is a very early version of where
we are and where we want to go so anyway
I have been asked to cut this off so we
will once again let's thank our
panelists and ask you please thank you
very much for attending and you know
let's the conversations continue thank
you very much